[Music]
as an architect I often ask myself what
is the origin of the forms that we
design what kind of forms could we
design if we if we wouldn't work with
references anymore if we have no bias if
we have no preconceptions what kind of
forms could we design if we could free
ourselves from from our experience if we
could free ourselves from our education
what would these unseen forms look like
would they would they surprise us but
they intrigue us would they delight us
if so then how can we go about creating
something that is truly new I propose we
look to nature Nature has been called
the greatest architect of forms and I'm
not saying that we should copy nature
are not saying we should mimic biology
instead I propose that we can borrow
nature's processes we can abstract them
and to create something that is new
nature's main process of creation
morphogenesis is the splitting of one
cell into two cells and these cells can
either be identical or they can be
distinct from each other through
asymmetric cell division if we abstract
this process and simplified as much as
possible then we could start with a
single sheet of paper one surface and we
could make a fold and divide the surface
into two surfaces we're free to choose
where we make the fold
and by doing so we can differentiate the
surfaces through this very simple
process we can create an astounding
variety of forms now we can take this
form and use the same process to
generate three-dimensional structures
but rather than than folding things by
hand we'll bring the structure into the
computer and encode it as an algorithm
and in doing so we can suddenly fold
anything we can fold a million times
faster and we can fold in hundreds and
hundreds of variations and as we're
seeking to make something
three-dimensional and we start not with
a single surface but with a volume
there's simple volume the cube if we
take its surfaces and fold them again
and
again again then after 16 iterations 16
steps we end up with 400,000 surfaces
and a shape that looks for instance like
this and if we change where we make the
folds if we change the folding ratio
then this cube turns into this one we
can change the folding ratio again to
produce this shape or this shape so we
exert control over the form by
specifying the position of where we're
making the fold but essentially you're
looking at the folded cube and we can
play with this we can apply different
folding ratios to different parts of the
form to create local conditions we can
begin to sculpt the form and because
we're doing the folding in the computer
we are completely free of any physical
constraints so that means that surfaces
can intersect themselves they can become
impossibly small we can make folds up
that we otherwise could not make
surfaces can become porous they can
stretch they can tear and all of this
expands the scope of forms that we can
produce but in each case I didn't design
the form I design the process of
generated the form in general if we make
a small change to the folding ratio
which is what you're seeing here then
the form changes correspondingly but
that's only half of the story 99.9% of
the folding ratios produced not this but
this the geometric equivalent of noise
the forms that I showed before were made
actually through very long trial and
error a far more effective way to create
forms I found is to use information that
has already contained in forms a very
simple form such as this one actually
contains a lot of information that may
not be visible to the human eye
so for instance we can plot the lengths
of the edges white surfaces have long
edges black ones have short ones we can
plot the planarity of the surfaces their
curvature how radial they are all
information that may not be instantly
visible to you but that we can bring out
that we can articulate
and that we can use to control the
folding so now I'm not specifying a
single ratio anymore to fold it but
instead I'm establishing a rule I'm
establishing a link between a property
of the surface and how that surface was
folded and because I've designed the
process and not the form I can run the
process again and again and again to
produce a whole family of forms
these forms look elaborate but the
process is a very minimal one there's a
simple input it's always a cube when I
start with and it's a very simple
operation it's making unfold and doing
this over and over again so let's bring
this process to Architecture how and at
what scale I chose to design a column
columns are architectural arch types
they've been used throughout history to
express ideals about about beauty about
technology the challenge to me was how
we could express this new algorithmic
order in a column I started using four
cylinders through a lot of
experimentation these cylinders
eventually evolved into this and these
columns they have information at very
many scales we can begin to zoom into
them the closer one gets the more new
features one discovers some formations
are almost at the threshold of human
visibility and unlike traditional
architecture it's a single process that
creates both the overall form and the
microscopic surface detail
these forms are undraw an architect
who's drawing them with a pen and the
paper would probably take months or it
would take even a year to draw all the
sections all of the elevations you can
only create something like this through
an algorithm the more interesting
question perhaps is are these forms
imaginable
usually an architect can somehow
envision the end state of what he is
designing in this case the process is
deterministic there's no randomness
involved at all but it's not entirely
predictable
there's too many surfaces there there's
too much detail one can't see the end
state so this leads to a new role for
the architect and one needs a new method
to explore all of the possibilities that
are out there for one thing one can
design many variants of a form in
parallel and one can cultivate them and
to go back to the analogy with nature
one can begin to think in terms of
populations one can talk about
permutations about generations
about crossing and breeding to come up
with a design and the architect is
really he moves into the position of
being an Orchestrator of all of these
processes but enough of the theory at at
one point I I simply wanted to jump
inside this image so to say I bought
these red and blue 3d glasses kind of
very close to the screen but but still
that wasn't the same as being able to
walk around and touch things so there
was only one possibility to bring the
column out of the computer there's been
a lot of talk now about about 3d
printing for for me or for my purpose at
this moment it's there's still too much
of an unfavorable trade-off between
scale and on the one hand and and
resolution and speed on the other so
instead we decided to take the column
and we decided to build as a layered
model made out of very many slices
thinly stacked over each other what
you're looking at here is an x-ray of
the column that you just saw viewed from
the top unbeknownst to me at the time
because we had only seen the outside the
surfaces were continuing to fold
themselves to grow on on the inside of
the column which was quite surprising
discovery from this shape we calculated
a cutting line and then we gave this
cutting line to a laser cutter to
produce and you're seeing a segment of
it here very many thin slices
individually cut on top of each other
and this is a photo now it's it's not a
rendering and the column that we ended
up with after a lot of work ended up
looking remarkably like the one that we
had designed in the computer almost all
of the details almost all of the surface
intricacies were preserved but it was
very labor intensive there there's a
huge disconnect at the moment still
between the virtual and the physical it
took me several months resign the column
but ultimately it takes the computer but
thirty Seconds to calculate all of the
16 million faces the physical model on
the other hand is 2700 layers one
millimeter thick that weighs 700
it's made of sheet that can cover this
entire auditorium and in the cutting
path that the laser followed goes from
here to the airport and back again but
it is increasingly possible machines are
getting faster it's getting less
expensive and there's some promising
technological developments just on the
horizon these are images from the
Gwangju Biennale and in this case I used
ABS plastic to produce the columns we
used a bigger faster machine and they
have a steel core inside so they're
structural they can bear loads for once
each column is effectively a hybrid of
two columns you can see a different
column in the mirror if there's a mirror
behind the column that creates a sort of
an optical illusion so where does this
leave us I think this project gives us a
glimpse of the unseen objects that await
us if we as architects begin to think
about designing not the object but a
process to generate objects I've shown
one simple process that was inspired by
nature there's countless other ones in
short we have no constraints instead we
have processes in our hands right now
that allow us to create structures at
all scales that we couldn't even have
dreamt up and if I may add at one point
we will build them thank you
[Applause]
[Music]